je discutais avec une jeune fille voilà
on décide de poursuivre la discussion
chez moi elle vient et elle me dit mais
je viens je suis avec une copine parce
que je suis pas toute seule et il y a
pas de métro c'est les métros sont pas
en convers donc est-ce que je peux venir
avec elle et je dis bah évidemment plus
on est fou plus on rit et donc du coup
bah oui mais j'avais pas le choix de moi
un verre et un moment une des deux celle
avec qui je discutais me dit tu veux pas
qu'on aille dans la chambre pour
discuter plus
longuement et Roger dans la chambre et
un moment elle reçoit un SMS et
j'entends la porte de chez moi claqué et
donc du coup ça j'ai des petits soupçons
et il me dit et c'est ma copine elle est
partie elle a plus de cigarette elle va
au distillée elle va acheter des
cigarettes mais sa carte passe pour
distributeur faut que je rejoigne on
revient elle part et elle revient pas et
puis au bout d'un moment donc du coup je
vais dans le salon je regarde il
manquait un tableau mon iPad et une
montre
c'est le déménageurs et
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un copain à moi qui m'appelle en
disant Jean-Michel tu as pas reçu rien
fait voler
incroyable ça c'était quelques heures
après je dis comment tu sais ça il dit
parce que la fille qui t'a volé ta
montre elle s'en est vantait elle l'a
vendu dans un quartier de Paris voilà en
18e elles sont des bandits c'est la
maman de Jean-Michel maire elle l'a
vendu à un prix qui était dix fois
inférieur à celui que je l'avais acheté
et elle s'en est montée mais j'ai après
j'ai essayé de retrouver mais j'ai
jamais retrouvé
très attention